djing tonight what can we expect
um
keeping the party going you know great
music doing commercial breaks great
music doing introductions of uh
nominations just keeping the party just
rocking this is what i do
we got a big award tonight miss jennifer
lopez getting the generation award
you've been in this business for a long
time with j.lo why is she so deserving
of this award i mean you got to think
about the depth and the range and where
she started and where she is and how she
continues to keep going on and
empowering women from the latin
community and just women in general like
i think about some of the most powerful
roles that she played like selena i
think about how impactful that was for
the latin community and just the way she
just manages to keep looking good every
year i mean she's amazing that's my home
girl keep doing your things j lo it is
well deserved so proud of you and you
you deserve it
speaking of women we heard you're
celebrating 25 years this year how are
you and the wife going to celebrate
borah boy
yeah believe that i'm taking off tonight
you understand me
straightener right getting one of those
those huts above the water yeah we're
gonna get a whole island you know what
i'm saying we gonna play with it we're
gonna go to the whole island we're gonna
just you know play with the dolphins and
have some fun give me a secret i'm
engaged what can you tell me about a 25
year marriage how do you make that work
happy wife happy life
i'm going to show him that to him yeah
that ain't got it ain't got nothing to
do with you that's all about him you
heard me
um you also have new music coming out
what can you tease about the new album
oh man mount westmore me ice cube too
short and e40 we created a super group
west coast group the album is called bad
mf's
um it'll be available tomorrow on gala
music and it'll be available on all
platforms in two weeks we just decided
to come together and put together an
album that represents us
west coast foundation unity brotherhood
and just great music what is it like to
work with those guys you've known them a
long time to get that group together and
be in the studio together i'm the baby
at a bunch so it's like i get to work
with all of my superheroes imagine you
know
having a movie with your favorite actors
and you get to play a role and they
respect you and they appreciate you and
you having more fun than anything
because you're with the guys that
inspires you to do what you do
do you what advice do you give to
younger people you know i just saw you
say hi to sweetie what advice do you
give to those younger artists just to
manage matters being you
manage the the terms of doing what you
do best and that's being you and being
creative and keeping stability on who
you are as a person
more than anything not as an entertainer
as a character but as a person maintain
that stability you guys gonna go on tour
you already know it real soon last time
i i had you on the carpet you smoked
right in front of me well we see any
smoke
no i ain't smoking tonight i'm trying
i'm trying to abide by the law you know
i've changed my ways i've become better
[Music]